all right we have to review cpac
the conservative political action
conference hosted by the american
conservative union
did you know they i feel like they just
did cpac in
in florida they did it again in texas
this weekend
we are going to go through uh speeches
we are going to go through
attendees we are going to look at the
results of the straw poll
it's just a big cpac day we're getting
all the cpac stuff out of the way
the first thing we're going to start
with is donald trump's speech
that he gave at cpac the big theme of
the speech
was trump telling lies about the
election
and also lots of really weird and
incoherent things
happening so let's just start going
through it we'll start with some of the
weird stuff
in this first clip trump's teeth
sort of chirp it's an unusual thing and
he launches
an attack of course on wind farms his
favorite enemy
and we don't need windmills in texas and
lots of other places
we don't need when they ought to end
that
program as quickly as they can so trump
there
illegal youth arrives and arrivals
overall illegal youth arrives
and arrivals are up nearly five yeah
so not only are youth arrivals up but
youth
arrives are also up and then trump
really getting into
i guess what we would sort of call the
meat of the speech
which is uh starting to talk about how
we actually won
and someone yells trump won and the
crowd just absolutely loves it
[Music]
[Applause]
it's true we all won we all won
yeah we all won yeah we we did really
um and then it starts to get more
confusing in this next clip trump
lists things that worked against him
during the election
but he still sort of won but it was like
they cheated but he won anyway
even though not really publicly
announced it i mean see if you can
follow this
then without any basis whatsoever
twitter and facebook
banned the new york post's account of
this
terrible story right after the election
one poll showed that at least 10 percent
of joe biden's voters would have
switched their vote
if they had known about joe and hunter
biden scandals
so this is the idea that the the hunter
biden quote scandal
about bringing three laptops across the
country to a blind guy
who's not sure but thinks because of a
sticker that they were probably hunters
hard drives but you know if that hadn't
been suppressed
by the so-called fake news media trump
would won enough to flip
the results of numerous states but he
won anyway right
that's the so but he would have won but
he won anyway
but don't worry about it because we won
those states anyway
wait a second so d did that make it so
you lost
but or did you actually win it's all
very very confusing and then trump
continued pushing this and as trump
likes to say if you repeat a lie
often enough people start to see it as
the truth
and he continued doing the vote rigging
stuff
every time the media references the
election hoax
they say the fraud is unproven true
and while there is no evidence no
evidence
no evidence there's so much evidence you
saw what happened in georgia the other
day they found 35 000
votes then they deleted in georgia
over a hundred thousand votes i said
because they were so
bad voters i said why didn't you try
doing it before the election the voters
were bad so they deleted votes i mean
this is this barely is english lost by
this much why didn't you do it before
the election
there's bad things going on in this
country so continuing to spread this
absolute nonsense trump then moved into
attacking his own former attorney
general bill barr he's actually attacked
bill barr a number of times now
including because barr didn't do enough
to take the election and he didn't go
after democrats enough and very casually
in this segment
trump also misstates what brett
kavanaugh was even accused of
i mean just it's all lies all the way
down said this because i didn't want to
but i will
i'm very disappointed that bill barr was
unable to hold anyone accountable
right for the countless abuses of power
by the democrats
the justice department wasn't operating
at the direction of trump
translated is what that means
he didn't hold the corrupt officials who
spied on our campaign
remember i said they're spying on our
campaign
that's of course another lie that
trump's been repeating for a long time
that was like a lightning rod went off
not the authors of the phony dossier
they weren't held responsible not the
women
who slandered and lied and defamed
brett kavanaugh they said brett
kavanaugh he had an affair
they didn't go after them they lied so
badly now of course brett kavanaugh was
not accused of having an affair he was
accused of sexual assault and rape
and so even misstating what it was there
this is also another funny thing check
out what
donald trump claims joe biden has done
in
his short time in office so far in a
matter of mere months
joe biden has brought our country to the
brink of ruin
[Laughter]
who could possibly believe that and the
answer is the people at cpac and later
we're actually going to be looking at
some of the interviews because remember
if people don't believe this trash
trump's in an empty room yelling at the
wall
the fact that the room is full with
people who believe it is as much a part
of the problem or even a bigger problem
than the fact that trump exists
then trump actually telling the truth
here i don't even fully get this but
trump says
being impeached twice made him even
worse
i don't know what he means but i think
he's actually telling the truth here
i understand that i didn't become
different i got impeached twice
i didn't check i became worse
i became worse okay trump saying
impeachment made him even worse
and that i actually do agree with that's
very true
almost beyond parody they're going back
to the migrant caravans
at any time that it's convenient it's
migrant caravans
thanks to democrats it's like
infrastructure week it's like clockwork
with these guys
we shut down the migrant caravans you
haven't seen those caravans
get ready because they're coming up
right they're bad watching them
come through and in those caravans you
have some deadly people
we you know i have to tell you i think
trump's disgusting but
if trump if someone went to him and
actually you know convinced him as he
likes to say they they go to him and
they say
sir sir exactly and they go sir
just promote the vaccine just go out
there and promote the vaccine and if
trump went out there and said guys
listen
you know how we cheer because i made the
vaccines this is the lie he tells his
supporters
the vaccine i made it's great for you
every single one of my patriotic
supporters
get the patriotic vaccine i got it in
january
i would actually my respect for trump
would go from zero to one or two percent
that that would dramatically increase my
respect for the guy
if he took these opportunities and
instead of talking about migrant
caravans
just straight up said get yourselves
vaccinated he's not doing it
instead he's back on the cognitive test
is it very easy for democrats to cheat
and to win elections you don't have too
many of them in texas do you louis
huh dr ronnie do we have the great doc
ronnie my doctor
yeah became a congressman right
he only beat 22 people 22 people he was
great
i said doc how about if i take a
cognitive test
he said well you can do it sir but if
you do you know
it'll be public oh i said what's wrong
with that he said well if you don't do
well sir it's not gonna be pretty
sir i said is it hard he said after the
first five questions it gets very hard
now we've already debunked that the test
is not difficult i said let's take a
shot at it
and we did it and we aced it right i
aced it
again these crowds cheering that trump
didn't
fail a test for serious advanced
dementia
that's now an applause line
[Applause]
and one of the doctors said he's never
seen anybody that aced it
and some of those sir no one's aced this
test before you have the littlest amount
of dementia of anyone we've ever looked
at
questions are not easy i will tell you
that tough stuff
how do you think joe would do in a
cognitive
all right so anyway there's trump back
on the cognitive test he's still talking
about hillary clinton by the way and
when he does
the crowd predictably starts chanting
lock her up lock up they're for law and
order and due process they say lock up
people not even
charged with crime crooked hillary
clinton
who by the way is the most angry person
in the united states today she's gone
away you know why
she said why the hell didn't you do that
for me
in 2016. forget it
there are more people than her so going
with the locker up stuff
trump here saying the quiet part out
loud about
polling this is funny because we knew
this was what was what he was doing
and he's saying it to his supporters by
the way you have a poll coming out
unfortunately i want to know what it is
they you know they do that straw poll
right
now if it's bad i just so i say it it's
fake
right if it's good
i say that's the most accurate poll
perhaps ever
that we we knew that's what he was doing
and yet his supporters laugh but he's
telling you the truth guys that's the
truth about trump's view on polling
and then lastly um capping the speech
with more lies
about the election and this will be a
big piece of 2022
and 2024. we will never give up our
search for truth
and justice for what happened in the
corrupt presidential election of 2020
because
without that truth we cannot have an
honest election
all that happened is he lost 2022 or
2024 no matter what they want to tell
you
and our country will soon stand
proudly for free and strong
and proper elections now of course we
mostly have them already
aside from some irregularities the real
election fraud is the voter suppression
that takes place
so a completely deranged speech we'll
look at some interviews with attendees
we will look at the straw poll we're
going to look at everything today as
well as some other things
we are now gearing up for the 16th
anniversary of the david pakman show
on august 16th it will be the 16th
anniversary of the show
and we are going to be doing a
membership blowout the likes of which
no doctors have ever even heard just get
on my newsletter
at davidpakman.com and then on august
16th you will get
something very special in your email and
a great opportunity to get a heavily
heavily discounted membership let me
know your thoughts about the trump
speech
you can find me on twitter at dpakman
and we'll be right back
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because
i know i won't be charged when the trial
is over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies
who you are you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman